c'est ici dans la cour de la maison
située dernière moins que le drame s'est
déroulé dans la nuit de samedi à
dimanche
vraisemblablement c'est une dispute
entre deux hommes d'une quarantaine
d'années qui a dégénéré en affrontements
violents
une voisine témoigne suis sorti j'ai
entendu effectivement un homme qui
gueulait quoi qui sans problème après
quelqu'un donc je suis rentré chez moi
j'étais dans ma chambre pour regarder ce
qui se passe c'est quoi donc j'ai vu que
ça se bagarre est que ça c'était quand
même très très fort donc on a vu un
homme à terre donc il continuait donc
ils l'ont roué de coups
on a entendu la dame qui nous a dit qui
a dit que bon effectivement qu'il ne
respirait plus donc elle s'est mis à
hurler à pleurer donc de là mon mari m'a
dit appelle tout de suite la police
j'ai appelé la police la victime était
originaire de montceau quant à l'auteur
présumé des violences il a été placé en
garde à vue au commissariat de montceau
les mines le parquet de chalon et saisit
de la sphère une enquête est en cours
une information judiciaire va être
ouverte un juge d'instruction sera nommé
dans la soirée